good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast
that's right yes that is the show that
you're watching don't get it twisted you
were confused this is the morning toast
and it is thursday
and it is a very warm thursday in the
city
a very cold thursday in our studio
they're trying to freeze us out
we're just a couple of working gals i
know that this is a real issue amongst
the corporate steens and we're just like
a couple gals you know who can't decide
what to wear to work and we're just so
like that yeah no it's actually this
isn't normal amount of air conditioning
like i'm gonna put the blanket on soon i
just wanted you guys to see my cute
outfit
wearing toast merch is the toastmark
kind of day you know i just woke up
tired yeah which is really shocking
because i usually wake up so brightly
fresh and energized but today was
different different
well honestly i just want to put it out
there like how not mad i am at this
current situation like yes
traveling to work in this big old
sweater not ideal
not gonna lie but showing up and sitting
in this icebox is so heavenly like
if you run warm like i do like you know
how much you're living for this dilemma
it's it's so crazy i think it's a
conspiracy against us
against you because i'm i'm so pleased
it's running
it's just it's so cold well sorry for
you i'm
loving life usually the show warms us up
all the hot news and hot takes of the
morning toast and hot
gossip oh the gossip it's so hot 100
percent
um yeah no today's gossip is i would say
it's lukewarm
definitely some interesting stories that
i'm excited to have you yell at me about
you know excuse me you know like you
know just like get fed up with
oh for sure a lot of china ain't going
on today no no no i did not choose the
fact that kristen
commented tristan tristan tristan
commented on chloe's instagram i was
this almost this desperate and i almost
chose it but i just knew you would never
forgive me so i didn't
ever and like two days before my
birthday i know you wouldn't do that to
me no but let's talk about your birthday
how are you feeling about everything
i'm feeling good today um is the day of
my part
day so tomorrow's episode will be in
studio it'll probably just be up like a
little bit later just so
some of us can nurse our hangovers um
i'm feeling good i'm feeling excited you
know
nervous of course there's always a
little bit of doubt when you throw a
party
um or maybe there's not and i just have
like crippling
anxiety but i'm feeling good i'm feeling
strong i have my glam
look picked out i've come doing
something crazy you know my makeup
artist courtney she knows like
bring the same tools every time like
we're never changing it up and i text
her like an inspo pic last night
and it's like purple which i i never do
and she was like shook to her core but
she's so down for the adventure
i might just scrap it and then go back
to the regular thing but i think i'm
gonna try something new
what color is your dress also a good
question the reason why theo is not here
today is i have to go buy one
this was really thrown together last
minute this party um and actually
nothing brings me more joy than running
around a store hot looking for a
last-minute outfit when nothing fits me
like i can't explain
how much joy that brings me it's such an
exciting adventure so i'm really looking
forward to doing that after this in my
sweatshirt so you know i'll be even
hotter
than i need to be yeah i made it about
three minutes and 50 seconds before i
had to go for the blanket
why don't you wear one of your retro
free dresses just like call it a day
wear the retro feet i think we should
talk about it okay
let's talk about the retro feet okay you
everyone knows the retro freak dress not
just from claudia but from the whole
world it's the dress
that everybody wears to every party
bachelorette party
can i talk about my experience with it
sure sure so
it was 2019. the year was 2019. i think
what year was i skinny for a year
was when we were so fabulous was it
before or after my wedding
before bw so that's why you got married
in early 2019.
this was january 2019. yes okay so just
to paint the picture like i was the
thinnest i'd ever been
in like 10 years not that it matters
just interesting for context
and i you know i've never been the type
of gal who just like there's like a
dress going around every season there's
a dress that everyone wears
and i've just never been the type of gal
to purchase it um because
that's just not the life that i have led
up until that point and because you're
not like other girls 100
and because usually the other girls are
just wearing something that is
trendy a trendy but also like not
friendly
towards people who aren't skinny yeah
or like with big titties like with big
titties 100 fake ones
so 2014 i'm going to mexico for my
friend on his wedding
and she is ashkenaz but she was marrying
someone
um he's yemenite and moroccan so they
had a henna
and a henna is like this big thing in
certain middle eastern cultures jewish
weddings
and it's like this big party and you
really need to wear like sparkles like
it's like it's not the rule but it's
like unwritten like you need a sparkly
dress
so i had just started shopping at
revolve because um they finally let me
in you know i finally lost enough weight
to be acceptable to revolve
and i had ordered a bunch of stuff and
i got a good stuff for the wedding and i
had bought this like gold sparkly dress
for the henna and it was really perfect
because it was really flattering like it
was
like loose so it was flattering and i
was just like excited about it
i didn't know that i had purchased like
the it dress at the moment and i was one
of like the first people to wear it and
honestly i don't have fashion moments
like that
so i re like i regard that moment and
that dress like with really high regard
okay
i looked amazing like unbelievably
stunning like the pictures from honest
henna like literally
i go back and look at them all the time
so then i had this dress
and i had worn i wore it again to a
friend's birthday party paris hilton i
don't know if you guys know her
um and it was like the perfect dress
because like no one at paris hilton's
party was gonna be out on his wedding no
one would have seen and like it was
perfect and it was enough time in
between
and then it was like every time i had
like somewhere to go where i needed to
look nice like
i had to wear the dress yeah and i
started wearing it so much and then i
was like you know what i should really
it is expensive but i was like i'm
wearing it so much like i shouldn't
invest in another color 100 so i did
pink
and where did i wear it to the bbmas
when we were escorted off the red carpet
because we didn't have the proper
wristbands
yes and i looked amazing and then i wore
the pink one
again to another event and i was like as
of like a month ago i'm like
i think i need a third one yep i bought
a third one in purple
where did i wear it to a hotel opening
in las vegas with my good friend paris
i'm not sure if you guys know her
um and it looked unbelievable and i've
gained
like a lot of weight since that first
initial dress but the size still fits me
and i still look amazing in it like i
looked a little bit better in it when i
was like skinnier but whatever like
the dress still fits so now i'm like at
this point in my life where are people
noticing
that i'm wearing the same dress to every
event no they're not and i'll tell you
why first of all you don't post pictures
when you out like you story but you
don't like do outfit of the night
pictures on
your whole instagram isn't like every
single time you wore that dress i mean
i'm sorry i forgot one more event i wore
the gold one too when we were in la and
we went to that fabulous uh fundraiser
for breast cancer research and the jonas
brothers played and like we were looking
so fabulous so sickening
literally the day coveted started it had
like just hit the scene yeah but we
still got in that last party
um so that's another one okay no i hear
you and
no they they have no idea they really
have no idea and if i were you i would
go
online right now and get the dress in
every color that they still make it in
yeah and then that's just your dress
also you're always like in situations
where you're with different groups of
people
and again you don't post outfit looks on
your instagram so your whole feed isn't
just like
what you wore and it turns out it was
the same thing every time
and if it looks good on you you get one
in every color like that's just the rule
do you think us currently shedding light
on it is working against me
well yes because now everyone's on to
you but i don't start the episode no
i feel like you needed some transparency
because you were feeling weird about it
and now that it's out there like
everyone can be in on it and like every
time you wear it everyone will be like
it's a dress
also more to ben's birthday party it's
all coming back to me ben's like 26th
birthday party a few years ago
it's like tiffany had a stress yes
except like tiffany addis has one dress
and i have like three now
yeah but also like hers was much more
expensive so it's actually all
adds up yeah so i'm still gonna go look
for an outfit if i don't find anything
it's so nice to know that i have those
three retrofit dresses and i take really
good care of them
that they're in a safe space and if i
need them that they are totally there
for me but i should try and like switch
it up you know
i think if it ain't broke don't fix it i
just feel like i
literally wore it two weeks ago like i
have to start no one who is going to
your party
that's true as well that is definitely
not untrue
so that's the truth i'm still going to
hit up one story
one store okay waste your time sure i
won't i won't stop you
whoo you want to come with me no i
actually thought about it but i think
i'm just gonna you know rummage through
my closet and find something
yeah pray for me i will it's so rough
it is so it's like i have plans to spend
my whole day like clamming up i'm gonna
do my own hair and makeup but like put
in rollers and everything and just
knowing what i'll probably wind up
looking like it just makes me sad that
happens to me all the time like whenever
i go out i have so much fun doing my
hair and makeup i'm listening to music
sometimes i go live on instagram but i'm
just like feeling myself i experiment
and then when the time comes to put on
clothes like i actually might as well be
going to the gym no and then i wear like
the same bodysuit and jeans
and like that's it and it's like not
special i was like what did i do all of
this for
it's so demoralizing it's so
demoralizing
there's a taylor swift lyric that i've
actually never related to more
i dress to kill my time like you know
when you're like it's a saturday you're
so are you starting your makeup four
hours early yeah that's me
yeah but no but still no matter how like
snatch the faces like
i really should pick out my outfit like
way before i get ready that way
it doesn't all collapse yeah but
sometimes what happens is like you have
you think you're like so good you have
an alpha picked out so you time
everything perfectly and then it's like
15 minutes before you're supposed to
leave the house you put your clothes on
and it's like disgusting no of course
and you're you're a slob i have a dress
in mine that i want to wear that like
just the last time i wore it i was just
a different girl and like i don't even
want to see what it's going to look like
but i don't know why i think that that's
what i'm going to wear well maybe you
should get a retrofit dress because
honestly i'm
i've been eight different girls since i
first bought that dress over two
no over over two years ago
yeah and it constantly just like brings
me back to
my center maybe i should you should get
one you look so good in it and they have
one well they make
two styles one that's a bow neck which
is great for big titted broads like us
and one that's like so sickening and
probably cuter that's like a wrap v-neck
kind of oh i don't know but
we can't wear v-necks no no that's fine
by me
boat i love a boat neck i ship [ __ ]
um so that's the long-winded discussion
on what we are wearing tonight
okay but i'm really excited for your
party and i hope so i'm just so nervous
to kick off your birthday celebrations
yeah but you know i'm just chill about
my birthday you know yes so
it's a three-day celebration so like in
what number
it's significant here's why i know it
just seems like i'm only turning 27 like
what's special about 27
i'm now wait is this sorry no it's not
i'm am i closer to 30 than i am to 25
when i'm 27 no no when you're 27 and um
a half in one day
okay so this is kind of like the last
birthday where i can say i'm equidistant
to 25 and 30. and that's why it's an
important birthday
okay whatever you need to tell yourself
thank you
um so yeah other than that great show i
guess we should get it moving so you can
go
shopping fruitlessly um don't worry i'm
in absolutely no rush to
go try on dresses like i think that if
you
could dream up the worst day like if you
if you were my enemy and you had to like
schedule a day for me
the whole day would be spent trying on
dresses that don't fit in a really hot
dressing room when i haven't eaten all
day like
that is my personal hell and that's why
i say yes to the dress
was such a terrible experience for me
totally but you're subjecting yourself
to that even though you have the right
dress sitting in your closet and that's
on you
100 well we have a great show for you
guys today yeah we do
because not only do we have like a
pretty decent
mixed bag of fast five stories it's what
mixed bag mixed bag yeah
we also have a juicy tv recap because
real housewives of beverly hills was on
last night and even though like not that
much happened i have so much to say
and two love island started last night
i've never watched it before jackie is
always the one giving recaps and i watch
it and i feel like such a part of a
community
and i'm so really a part of something
with love island because it's five
nights a week and that's what i crave
but did she say
six weeks six weeks it goes on for six
weeks
yeah i guess so she didn't say that she
said that she did it i'm like is it six
weeks your time or like does it air six
weeks but then i realized
it's all in real time like what we
watched last night like it like filmed
two or three days ago yeah so um
i don't know if i'm gonna make it all
the way just because like i'm really not
good with like committing to things but
i'm really gonna try
yeah whatever whatever works for you
especially like it's a hot girl summer i
don't know if i'm gonna be home every
night watching love island no but like
it's nice to have
content waiting for you and to be a part
of something and i really am excited for
you to have that feeling and i'm excited
to recap it in the tv recap segment
can't wait okay so i guess without
further ado
to do where are you not here but it's
fine because it's way too cold
um here are the fast type stories that
you probably could
stand to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
[ __ ] sorry it's just my rth flaring up
that was good acting did i get anyone
yeah it did yeah it looks like you're
like making duty no i was i don't know
what i was like pointing at but i
i think i was like i really laid the
groundwork like i started like
a thing like 45 seconds ago oh my god
okay was the camera on me
i think it was on both of them yeah um
today's episode is brought to you by
olive in june and my rdh is cured by
telling you that
you cannot possibly do your nails
yourself and it's time that you come to
grips with that like stop walking around
with crusty
nails that aren't being done by olive
and june because unless you're using the
olive and june manicure set your nose
are gonna look crusty and do you wanna
be crusty no it's hot girl summer
and then they always chip and that's
just like so sad do not be the girl with
chip nails like
don't olivan june manny system is the
best way to do a diy mani you can do it
at home and they last
over seven days it is possible to do a
manicure at home that lasts over seven
days i know you didn't think so but
that's because you haven't heard of
olive in june yet
um the system comes with all the tools
that you need in one box they've got a
buffer a nail file
cuticle oil this great little rubber
topper that you put on top of a bottle
of polish so when you're using it in
your hand it really helps
steady your hand and financially it just
makes a lot more sense because the mani
system
comes with with six polishes breaks down
to just two dollars a manicure so if
you're used to spending
35 dollars for one gel manicure it
really makes sense fiscally and we
care about your physical responsibility
here at the morning toast our nails have
never looked as good
at home as they do with olive and june
and jackie was like obsessed with doing
her nails in quarantine and olive and
june like
the whole toolkit you really cannot
compare
like an animal manicure kit and caboodle
like not only do they make it so easy
for you to paint your nails but they
give you everything you need to do like
the whole
the works the cuticle oil the filing
ever the buffing
everything that you need and you do need
to do those things the olive and june
mounting system is the secret behind
salon perfect nails at home all in one
no guessing
no messy nails and no salon price tag
and now you can get 20 off your first
manny system with code toast
your new nail life is here get 20 off
your first mani system when you use the
promo code toast
at olive and june.com we're done with
expensive bad manicures this is the new
us
thank you for that claudia you are so
welcome now
our first story um a little love
triangle news sort of not really brian
austin green
says he and megan fox are getting along
great after quote
petty digs brian austin green refuted
claims that he was shading estranged
wife megan fox in a loved-up instagram
post with current girlfriend
sharna burgess the former beverly hills
90210 star spoke out on wednesday after
many fans felt he was being rude towards
fox when he wrote of burgess he said
it's been a really long time
since i've been with someone i can truly
share life with
he said for people that need or want
clarification megan and i get along
great neither of us are sending petty
digs to each other
well forgive us for being confused
because you sent petty digs to each
other for so many years
yeah no and then like megan commented on
that post of him and sharna
love charlotte grateful for sharna so
like
no offense that's sociopathic behavior
and it's weird even if you are like
really
good like i think of who are like the
two most healthy co-parents in hollywood
like honestly
courtney and scott like they co-parent
really well and let's say
scott put up a picture with a girl at
amelia for for instance and was like so
glad to have found someone i can share
my life with
and courtney commented love amelia like
that is weird so
of course we're going to be confused
because your guys are acting like freaks
after you've been
so [ __ ] mussy right for years that's
important that they've been so messy
about everything for so long
also i thought for a second sharna
burgess i didn't know who she was and i
thought she was travis barker's ex
just shannon moekler it's very confusing
very confusing then i googled her she's
from dancing with the stars sharna
shana is travis's ex
because then i was like oh my gosh this
goes even deeper because megan machine
travis sharna 100 but no
sharna and shanna are different
okay honestly but have you seen them in
the same room together
no no and until you have you can't tell
me otherwise
no it's it is like an uncommon name
so um it's possible it is an uncommon
name that only one of them has
it's the same yeah it's the same sharna
burgess
soon to be green shannon burgess green i
i actually like
did feel bad for a while for brian
austin green because megan fox rebounded
in such a shipworthy way
and like the whole world just kind of
rallied behind megan fox and megan
king edmonds this megan
kell machine gun kelly machine megan
okay it's a mouthful megyn kelly the
couple
they rebounded well she rebounded with
him and like it was this global story
like
everyone from like the rock world
everyone was obsessed because they're so
stunning and it kind of never went away
like i'm still obsessed
it still has that sparkle it didn't
fizzle and like
the music videos like there was just so
much content for us to absorb and that
must have been really hard for brian
austin green
who is like already known for being a
has been like he hasn't worked
since 90210 so he's like a husband and
now he's a husband in his personal life
so like i did feel bad for him but then
like when i got all messy on instagram i
was like
not here for that like he was using the
kids to like say that megan fox was like
[ __ ] her boyfriend too much that she
couldn't like
be with the kids which i really didn't
appreciate that like the kids have two
parents
[ __ ] off um i'm glad that they're in a
good place now and i did feel bad for
brian austin green and i do hope he
finds someone he can share his life with
and
it's a wonderful thing and it seems that
he has in charne sharna to the rescue
okay well that's the latest with them um
love to see some happy co-parents yeah i
didn't appreciate his tone in the story
it's like guys like it's not petty like
sorry that you two have led us to
believe this entire time right it would
be
that everything you do is petty so it's
not really on us i think you need to
take some responsibility for yourself
and the pattern you've set
thank you i agree are you ready for our
next story which is an exciting list
no no it's really a good one give me a
chance okay
28 books that are being made into movies
and tv series that you should read ahead
of their release
what do you think okay you've gotten me
on the kindle train but like don't test
me okay
okay no but like sometimes it's you want
to know what books are have i read any
of these
you've read or heard of some of them but
also i do think that the toasters might
want to know because sometimes if
something's being made into a movie
you want to read the book first yeah so
here the last letter from your lover by
jojo moyes
adele said my love to your new lover
if that's not like the intro of the
movie i'm not finishing it
okay i think that's fair honestly i just
gave you a million dollar [ __ ] idea
run with it i think that's
a fair stipulation i haven't read this
book but i did read one book by jojo
moyes i think i chose the wrong book
but jojo moyes also wrote me before you
that atrocious movie yeah um
also i do feel like we speak about this
a lot how so many books get
bought but never get made by the idea
this one is a list of what is confirmed
yeah this is from variety like i think
these things are in the production okay
the reincarnation is papers
by eric macron's number that's not our
um
vibe but as far as mark wahlberg
honestly
i would watch mark wahlberg like brush
his teeth for two hours like die for him
and really just want to support him
after
he gave us the gift of ted you know i
feel like he doesn't get enough
respect for that and for that i will
always be a fan because he really kind
of
first of all he strengthened the bond
between me and my sisters like that
movie really gave us so much
and it's premium premium comedy and
none of people talk about it and i think
it's disgusting i really do the book
description actually sounds good so
if you're into the reincarnationist
paper so you have a lot to look forward
to
american rust by philip meyer not didn't
read it
dune by frank herbert
the last duel of true story of crime
scandal and trial by combat in medieval
france can you just get to the ones
we've heard of house of gucci that's the
one that's going to be with lady gaga
and adam
yeah okay can we also talk about how
lady gaga has just been like
so stunning recently like have you seen
these press photos of her she was in
italy and now she's at the plaza
and she's just like her hair is brown
and she's looking truly like
like a house of gucci like dead ass like
she looks stunning she really takes on
the role i feel like when she was doing
press for or just like around the time
where
star is born was coming out she was
giving me like alley vibes and now she's
really giving me like gucci vibes i
don't know who she plays but
also the film also stars jared leto and
al pacino i feel like they've kind of
gotten shafted in all the press
that's what happens when lady gaga when
there are 99 people in a room
yeah and lady gaga is one of them next
one that you've heard of the nightingale
by kristin hannah
it's going to be starring l and dakota
fanning um because the book is about two
sisters
oh my god love two sisters actually
playing sisters book
is amazing really every if you've read
it
you love it if you haven't you should
it's so [ __ ] good it's um like a
world war
ii you know what book i really need to
start keeping a list because i haven't
been in the mood to read
okay but when i do get there what was
that one called
the nightingale by kristin hannah the
nightingale by kristin hannah it's like
everyone's number one historical fiction
favorite malibu rising
what was the one lions dancing lion's
den you guys lion lion
i just need to have a list for like when
the day comes when i actually do want to
pick up my kindle it's just been a while
i just haven't been motivated
okay fear street by r.l stein
um i'm just gonna go to ones that you've
heard of nine perfect strangers by
leanne moriarty
did i read that one no but leon moriarty
wrote big little
lies oh and nine perfect strangers is
about nine
strangers at a wellness retreat oh
you're telling me about this starring
nicole kidman
oh yeah yeah i've heard about this so
good i'm actually oh and luke evans
and melissa mccarthy and guest show
among others
so it's gonna be a hulu series i'm so
excited about this and i'm actually not
reading the book because i don't want
my perception of the show to suffer
three
two one
that wasn't our best i thought it was
good i went low on my nodes kicked in
jackie when they go low you go high no i
went low
when they go high where the crawdads
sing by dalia owens i just want to know
like when someone's going to make it
ends with us like it's literally
jenzy is obsessed with that book it's
all over tic toc it's become like the
biggest thing
it's like a coming of age thing like you
you become a woman when you read that
book like they should make you read it
before your
mitzvah like i haven't read it what i
haven't read it
overall yeah oh my god do you think i
shouldn't
oh my god you have to read it okay i'll
add it to my list oh you'll finish it in
one day like it's literally the most
stunning book it has it all it has like
are you ready to receive my wrath though
if like recommending a book to someone
you know this is a fool it's like
recommending the seven husbands of
evelyn hugo like it's uh
okay i can't believe you haven't read it
these are big things
oh my god you guys it's literally i know
everyone has read it so it's so stunning
and like it's all over tik tok now it's
finally hit gen z
and i can't believe nobody has like
purchased it it's the best story ever
okay well i'll keep you posted yeah and
you know colleen hoover loves to throw a
little porn in there so
there's plenty of that nice then lord of
the rings i'm pretty sure that was made
but been there done that
conversations with friends by sally
rooney you're probably like why do i
care but sally ruining
normal people which is the best on hulu
and literally the craziest sex scenes so
if you haven't seen it i did
not like the the show and i i finished i
didn't finish the show because i didn't
like it and i
didn't love the book either i think i
gave it a three you didn't like the show
no it just
it made me i found it to be really
depressing well yes they were both like
just so annoying it was too dark
i loved it and it was a dark time i
couldn't i was like i need uppers
obsessed with paul mezcal and his penis
was in it so you should watch it again
no i i it's okay i read the book so i
know what happens i feel okay about that
obviously
daisy jones and the six i don't want to
trigger you but that is
soon triggered a 13 episode mini series
on amazon prime
can't wait to not to literally cancel my
prime subscription just so i don't have
to see the commercials
the vanishing half by brit bennett which
is a hugely popular book
will now be on hbo that's exciting
and then a malibu rising oh
but they don't say who is going to be in
it but it's going to be in hulu
well i literally um just
just started it like i haven't even take
your time because it seems like they
haven't cast it yet okay
we actually we did a mini malibu rising
recap on the redheads uh where
because three of us had read it where we
talked about like who we would cast i
don't think anybody answered my question
but i
really saw which is so weird for young
nina
i don't even know that there's a young
you know like please don't spoil it okay
so is there an old nina this is sort of
it's like
that i know i don't i don't want to hear
so i shouldn't say who i
know i saw it no because then it'll like
go in my mind and i want to come up with
someone myself
okay but then we'll we'll circle back
off yes okay okay cool
speaking of circling back our next story
is some exciting suz news
we are circling back on the drama the
crisis
in the suez that we were really kind of
thought leaders
raptured by and now ever get bitten
evergreen
yeah but it says ever given on bbc the
ship that blocked the sweze canal is
setting sail
after a deal has been signed so the ship
has still been
right people don't know like there it
unblocked it and then they had to chill
because they had to pay like a billion
dollars in
yeah the ship was impounded for three
months near the canal city of ismailia
and by the way people who were working
on the cargo ship like had to stay on
the boat
yeah so now the ship has left the port
and there is footage showing the captain
and the crew being presented with
flowers
and a plaque on board the ship which
seems a little like
extra considering like they got stuck we
know i'm confused now because
so they couldn't leave because they were
in trouble right like they had to
be punished right i guess so they had to
come to a deal
with egypt i mean anyway the terms of
the deal have not been shared
anyone who was on that boat and first of
all got stuck and then had to stay on
that smelly boat for three more months
like deserves medals and flowers
but like who gave it to them i'm just
like the like the people of egypt
and maybe yeah maybe people who have
been like if i lived in egypt like
i would literally be at the suez every
day like talking to people on the boat
getting facts negotiating the deal
and just kind of being like a liaison
yeah
i would go down to the suez all the time
and just like wave to the ships
no the suez and i would also just kind
of like swim in it
and pretend i was luanne de la sapps
well then you would cause like some
dramas
whatever you can't swim in the sun you
cannot swim in the suez why not
i i don't know and i don't know that's
for sure but in my i know for sure you
can just like dip your toes in
no you can't take a dip in the sweats a
dip in the sweats
endless days in my shades the
okay well that's their latest swizz news
the ship is leaving lifeguards imported
from egypt
cargo imported from suez
not your best no okay i'll work on it
there's something there for sure
100 like uh if somebody wants to write
the lyrics to
a cover of that song just all about the
suez i actually think it could be like a
viral sensation
i think you could be the one to do it
you just need to like take the time
to try it's not going to be improv yeah
you need to try
you cannot swim in the city don't swim
there are poisonous and venomous things
we are hearing we have confirmation that
you can't swim in the sweat so please
don't try it and then say you heard
about it on the morning toast because
you're saying that you can't swim in the
sweat swim in the sea literally
don't take risks on treacherous canals
and this is a treacherous one
anyways missed you suez they should
really clean that up
what the suez is as important meant to
be swim
swam in well then why is it there
i just think like if it's what i've
learned through this whole journey is
that the suez is such an important
geographical trade route and literally
any problem with it can cause billions
and dollars of dollars and millions of
people
trouble yeah so don't you think the
water should be clean
yeah why the ships are just going to
muck it up again
no i think that they should work
i would like to talk to someone from the
suez
panel you're wasting your time i don't
think so i think so i don't think so
we're ready for our next story a little
food news oh food news that's brought to
you which is perfect because i'd love to
eat in my bed by bowling branch
bowl and branch is the best sheets on
the market and if you're looking to
refresh your bed which i did a few
months ago and it's such a game changer
like
if you spend as much time in your bed as
i do or even if you just sleep in your
bed
it should be a safe warm and cozy place
and bowling branch is a great place to
start
um so i jackie and i both have uh
the whole set it's so comfortable what i
was really worried about is that i get
really warm in my sleep
and i don't like sheets that are like
kind of like suffocating but the bowling
brand sheets are so breathable
that i really don't notice a shift like
i just
seamlessly sleep and i don't sweat extra
the cloud weight super soft
satin weave gets softer with every watch
wash we have the 100 organic signature
hemmed sheets
they're beautiful and stunning obviously
but they also feel so good
they're crafted to the highest standards
and attention to detail from sourcing to
packaging
and they are the perfect balance of
weight and breathability to pamper warm
or cool sleepers throughout any season
the sheets are designed and manufactured
for maximum comfort and durability
they don't cut any corners over at
bowling branch you get luxury quality
for the fairest price because there's no
middleman between you
and bowling branch and they stand behind
their products so they have a 30-night
worry-free guarantee if you are
unsatisfied with the products which i
don't think you will be
um and if you want to experience an
entirely new standard of comfort visit
bowlingbranch.com
get 15 off your first set of sheets with
promo code toast
at b-o-l-l and branch
dot com promo code toast it's the best
thing you can do
self-care sometimes self-care looks like
getting yourself some new sheets
sometimes self-care looks like chicken
tenders
i couldn't agree more beyond meat
launches new meat-free chicken tenders
in u.s restaurants beyond meat unveiled
an
improved meat-free chicken recipe that
uses a mix i don't want to tell you
what's in it because then you won't like
want to eat it
but i mean i don't need to eat it
because i eat chicken but you should eat
i will be eating it i'll be making you
eat it because what's in it
you want to know yeah i mean whatever
what is it duty
yes so what's in it
fava beans and peas it's gonna be a no
for me
for a total of 14 grams of protein per
serving the new tenders will debut
in nearly 400 us restaurants on thursday
which restaurants
didn't say but beyond me needs a [ __ ]
website store locator like 100 persons
or they should start opening like their
own franchises because okay great you're
coming out with this product where can i
get it
a hundred and fifty percent they need
store locators because
i want these tenders today you know of
course like let's postmates them and do
like a mukbang look how [ __ ]
delicious that looks
wow that actually does look really good
and you would be getting all the fava
beans and peas that you need in your
daily diet thank god i'm actually like
really
pretty much usually hit my limit for
fava beans and peas because that's what
i have every day so
i actually don't really need this oh
okay well just in case there's
a deficit i really want this for you
because honestly i know how much
joy happiness and just overall peace i
get when biting into a chicken tender
and you're really not able to experience
that because you don't eat chicken so
i need i need you to have this just so
you can experience the joy that i've
experienced so many times
yeah i really do need this in my
rotation a food because like yeah we
have the mc plant out there
but sometimes you don't want to make
plans like it's a lot of different
flavors
and didn't you send me an article that
like i forget which chain or was a few
chains are reporting very
low sales for certain mcplant not the
mcplant
at duncan they're like beyond they're
walking back on it
sandwiches are not performing well and
so they're like taking them off the menu
and
i mean i never ordered one so and you're
the person who should have ordered one
but i don't order a breakfast sandwich
you like i just feel like
and i've heard they're not good and
they're not good we have a source that
says they're not good
no i'm curious i think out of all the
bed veggie options we've gotten in the
last couple of years i have to assume
that the most successful one is the
impossible whopper
one because it was the first one out two
they did so much marketing for it and
three
you you've tried it you said it's
amazing yeah you know i still haven't
tried mid planned
we because we haven't done our
literally since last summer i know okay
we'll do it this summer let's try and do
it this month
uh you know i'm you never have to
convince me to get into a car and drive
to mcdonald's like
ever okay you know what we should do on
our on our mukbang
subway oh my god but only if it could be
drive-through
well then we can't well then we can't no
we have to find the one intense
store no i think that's a good idea i
think so too well anyways
false meat eaters you can get excited we
have more alternative
more alternatives alternations
alternatives yeah i also would just like
to implore anyone who works on the
marketing team
at beyond meat company like store
locator
restaurant locator grocery store locator
i don't really feel like it's that hard
no
no you're really onto something yeah i
know i think that's also i'm just giving
out every all these companies million
dollar ideas today
yeah i mean you're just generous crazy
generous chris
generous are you ready for our fifth and
final story that's going to lead into
our tv recap
because it's a little um you know
gerardi gate news wait is it the final
story
[Music]
someone's in a singing mood today today
no like you've been singing a lot today
yes i have
okay you guys here's the latest in the
gerardi it's really bad
tom girardi's embezzlement victims can
collect payments from erica girardi a
drug
a drudge rules a judge rules a judge
ruled tuesday that
some foreign judges ruled the world
juror ruled tuesday that some former
clients of tom gerardi
can pursue collections lawsuit against
his estranged wife erica
the ra gomez family who we learned about
in that documentary the housewife and
the hustler
are eligible to sue erica jane for the
11 million dollars that they are owed
yep exactly and after seeing you know
erica's
small home i don't think she's got it i
don't know if she has 11 million dollars
but it's like
she got we know she got 20 million from
from
from tom tom took money out of his
company which is illegal
gave it to his wife put it in her like
llc company
which makes no sense as alone um
unclear if erica knew where that money
was coming from say that 20 million was
blown through and like it doesn't exist
anymore they can still
get the money like from her other you
know shoedazzle ventures like
you know now it's not just that 20
million it's erica jane as a whole
yeah this is really bad bad
yeah and so now it begs the question
because we've been talking about this
recently like jen shaw
erica jane where do we go from here as
you know housewives fans
when it comes to keeping these people on
the show because yeah it's super
entertaining but it is some sort of like
ethical dilemma
um and now i feel like we're at the
point where erica jane whether or not
like they want to keep her on for the
drama like it's a show about rich women
and it seems like she
is no longer that yeah and if she is
like she has some bills to pay like the
eligibility requirement for being on the
real housewives of beverly hills is
um living in beverly hills and having
money yeah and erica jane
as far as i know lives in west hollywood
now and doesn't appear to have a lot of
money
yeah also i think as far as like taking
her off the show for
um ethical reasons it's still
too early to call because the case is
ongoing and i think if andy said that
from the documentary housewife and the
hustler that if there's not enough there
to jeopardize her standing on the show i
still think that nothing has really come
out that would jeopardize her standing
but it's still early on yes
so this is just like a bad development
for erica jane like it's not looking
good
which leads into our tv recap which we
have a lot to talk about about the
episode and i hate to skip to like what
they showed us for next week but
scene of like erica crying her makeup
off um
i guess that's the week where like the
lion air stuff comes out
well so honestly like even though this
was a fine episode we are all waiting
for the other shoe to drop and so
it's just kind of frustrating to get
none of it and so i have a feeling
whenever we see of erica crying will be
like the last two minutes of next week's
episode of course and it's just
frustrating because that's really what
this season is all about and as much as
like i could really talk about this
crystal and sudden drama forever because
it's so [ __ ]
stupid i've expired it's not what we
came here for
yeah so i liked last night's episode i
thought there was a lot of really
interesting things and
we always say this like a bad episode of
real housewives of beverly hills this
season
is literally better than the best
episode of real housewives of new york
this season like it's just not even
comparable so i don't even
not enjoy i enjoy the bad episodes but
i'm really waiting for
we have non-stop talking about erica
jane and the show has not given us one
thing to talk about
yeah the only thing is like if next week
is about
a lot of the stuff coming to light the
orphans and widows and what
tom was actually doing this week showed
us that she was
about to like be on her feet from the
divorce like we saw her house
it looks super cute she's all set up
like the rooms are really nice she had
the girls over like
she was in a good place i don't know if
she knew that more was coming
but it will make like what happens next
on the from the show's narrative
standpoint like
a lot worse yeah and we're also like
it's also difficult to know like
what erica j knew and like is this she
just like acting you know yeah
she is an actress she was on the ball to
the beautiful with eileen davidson
no and she's a theater yeah person yeah
person yeah no no there's it's very
possible that like she's just showing us
some sort of calculated manipulated
storyline of what actually happened
yeah we'll we'll get to that next week
but let's talk about what happened this
week which is
just mostly housewives it was a hard
episode for me because it was so much
less arena and i've gotten to a place
where i i literally
cannot stand her like yeah and even
harry hamlin who
really i think for a lot of the show has
kind of grounded erica i
groundedly said so many people love
harry and so many of the it wasn't
enough for me
it was not enough okay i feel i totally
agree with you and it was like it pains
me to say something nice but like that
after the lunch in their backyard was so
stunning and like
to have your husband cook a home-cooked
meal for your friends from the
vegetables in his garden was just like
such a lovely touch
and also to do all of that for garcelle
and i
i'm with garcelle 100 like we are mad at
reyna but to have someone throw you a
birthday party not just like oh i rented
out this room at this hotel and i called
the cat
in your home in your home like homemade
meals
i agree the cake and the everything like
the gift she
really and but lisa renner will stop at
nothing for forgiveness
and for just like everyone to like her
and for continuation on the show so if
it means like
you know going full stop for garcelle
that's what she's gonna do and i think
garcelle knows that and i i think
garcelle was kind of going between like
being touched but also like knowing what
was really going on yeah but i think
like you can be touched
i think that you should be touched
because what she did was lovely it was a
really
lovely afternoon her her the grounds of
her home are so
beautiful and it was a really lovely
setting
i agree i thought it was and i would
love to try harry's bullying they say i
really would it was really bothering me
when they kept calling it bolognese like
you're in malibu's bolognese like yeah
it was really annoying me um i agree it
was
a really a lovely afternoon and like a
perfect coved like i if i had lived
in a home during kobe like i would have
had everyone over for bolognese and
tequila like
every night yeah outside like that it
looked lovely
um but here's where i feel like for the
last couple weeks every time we talk
about the sutton
and crystal drama like i am back and
forth i was first first with crystal
then i was with sutton and now i'm kind
of back with crystal like
what breakdown like that random
breakdown she had when everyone got it
it seemed
sutton is triggered by being left out we
noticed that in tahoe when like she
thought everyone was in on a joke about
her it wasn't about her but she did feel
left out and that triggered her
seeing kathy kyle and crystal go in on a
gift together
that's what triggered sutton she's very
weird she had such an
overreaction to whatever the hell was
going on like i don't know why she that
whole
birthday thing like started to bother
her and she got up and started crying
she is slightly unhinged and that's why
we love her but like it's very hard to
defend her like i didn't really know
no one was talking about the peeping
topic i mean she walks into the party
for a sensitive woman she walks into the
party and the first thing she's called
is thomasina
it was funny i don't know who that is
but no no me neither but i think it's
like a joke like yeah like peeping tom
sort of thing
no i know but so it's like okay so
that's who she is in the group and not
everyone's still over it and there's no
resolution between her and crystal and
some people can just move on
and it's like i think for me i would
just want to avoid confrontation that
it's like okay we're not gonna we are
gonna
agree to disagree let's let's try again
but for sutton it's not resolved and she
feels really awkward and she's an
awkward person so it's like doubly
awkward
what do you think crystal meant by like
you're jealous um
i think she meant that like sutton is
like newly divorced and
i think she lives uh like or and with
her husband had lived like a life at the
same level as crystal like i think they
run in like a similar
sphere and crystal life is
intact and she's if that's the case
that's a really mean thing to say yeah
that's
just the vibe that i got me too like
very
jackie goldschneider like i win no but
like
theresa is jealous of jackie like
hundreds of flirting with her husband
and i don't think that's true of sutton
first of all i think when you're
fighting with someone and you say we're
only fighting because you're jealous of
me it's like
so cop-out yeah
like it's just it's just a lame thing to
say and also all the women in the group
a lot of them are happy like kathy
hilton came
in the same time as crystal she has ever
the same things and
and sutton's not beefing with her so
like i it's it's just a lame thing to
say and i
i understood why sutton was triggered by
her upset
and then she hit us with ugly leather
pants so funny
so funny sorry great a great comeback
yeah it took her a minute though
yeah it took her all the way to get up
the hill but to come up with something
to say
also i did absolutely love getting to
see kathy hilton's house it was
everything i dreamed of and more it was
so stunning and she lives right near
crystal which means it's like a
sickening area
the backyard was so gorgeous and then
they went inside for like tea or
whatever it was
glorious like exactly what i expected
when we signed up for kathy hilton yeah
also her not knowing
what hunky dory means that was really
funny that was funny and like
is that possible that she doesn't know
what hunky dory is
i mean i don't know what time cena is
that's so true thomasina
you know some people just have different
references so true
um other than that what else happened
you know what i've actually been
realizing these last couple episodes
dorite is irrelevant yeah and honestly
the one thing she we got from her last
night's episode is talking about like
her designing bridal which is
i'm sure the dresses are beautiful but
like this is what we keep saying like
the franchise in the last couple years
has elevated so much
and it's like kathy hilton like just
sitting in her palace drinking tea and
like jerry's talking about like
designing a bridal collection like
it's just a little it's just not going
to work for me
i understand i i have way more patience
than you do and i think that
it's just because darie's not involved
in the drama right now but i think she
can still hold her own i think dorite
also put a lot of the drama on her back
for the last couple seasons like she and
kyle were the ones
who started that holy savannah pump
thing like the dog
so actually maybe she just wants a break
from like
from like having to like be the bad guy
yeah i agree me too
um it was a good episode again nothing
like crazy happened but i still enjoyed
it and i really just love seeing the
gals get together
yeah same and i'm i'm really over the
crystal in certain drama
but until like crystal's not gonna be
able to move on from it until there's a
resolution but like
i'm sorry sutton won't be able to move
on but crystal is not changing her tune
so where do you go from there i don't
know
i don't know yeah and like honestly i
know i i kind of relate to crystal
because
when you really don't feel like you did
something wrong like you don't want to
apologize i'm like i'm very stubborn
like that too like if i
if i feel like i did something wrong or
like i really will apologize but if i
don't find
wrong in what i did like go [ __ ]
yourself but sometimes just like saying
an apology for someone who's like so
clearly upset by something
makes it so much easier but she's not
going to give that to her so we're going
to talk about this for a long time which
is really annoying when like literally
erica is like
maybe when erica bobshell drops like
everyone will just kind of get in line
yeah hopefully yeah but i thought like
the bombshell was dropping
but i guess right now to them it's just
like erica decides to get a divorce
period
well think about it they're talking
about thanksgiving and then erica files
on election day so
when did the lion air stuff come out
because it's not even thanksgiving yet
yeah so we can track the timeline
probably in december but then they get
covered
oh so that's and that's why garcelle is
talking to kyle on her
phone on the balcony too oh my god
you're 100
right that's so annoying that like the
juiciest time
is when they have to stop down filming
for kovid
december's last january okay so maybe
maybe we'll get
yeah well that'll be interesting to see
and the other part of our tv recap
segment which is brought to you by
noom is our love island recap so stay
tuned for that
new their cognitive behavioral approach
helps you unlearn bad habits and better
understand your relationship
with food because you don't need rules
to lose weight just the knowledge and
wisdom to help you build smarter more
sustainable habits
when it comes to losing weight there's a
lot of pressure out there to label foods
as good or bad
but that just creates unnecessary
dilemmas not everyone wants to be on a
strict diet do two days two a days at
the gym or drink questionable teas
instead of trying to cram your life into
someone else's idea of health try new
nume uses a psychology-based approach to
find a healthier balance that's molded
to fit your life as a result it becomes
more sustainable
eighty percent of numerous finish the
program and over sixty percent of them
have stuck with their goals for the last
year one size does not fit all choose
your goals and noon will personalize a
weight loss program
just for you and with noob taking care
of your health is empowering instead of
stress inducing
there's no need to fear ruining the
whole program with one day off they will
help you get back on track
all you need is 10 minutes daily to
check in there's no grueling early
mornings or huge chunks out of your day
i know you've had a lot of success with
noom can you tell me a little bit about
that yes i
love new my favorite thing about it is
probably just like the support that you
feel knowing that there is this like
platform
that has your back and that you can go
to turn to if you have questions or you
slip up or you just want that
consistency
so my favorite thing about neum is
probably the calorie tracker just
because sometimes you don't realize like
what you're eating and what's in it and
also they like let you know like
grams of fat protein and all adds up and
so to see your day at a glance
with noom it's everything of the sort
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results
sign up for your trial at noom.com toast
that's
n-o-o-m-dot-com toast to sign up for
your trial
all right love island i've never watched
it before okay
i had a few initial thoughts please
share one i've never watched a reality
show on cbs i just thought that was
interesting
two ariel vandenberg is the host yes ben
is like 100 in love with her because
really okay so i told you ben had become
like really into are you the one and
last night he wanted to watch i'm like
i'm actually starting this new show that
it's like a similar premise to these
dumb shows we've been watching like i
think you'll enjoy it
so he was like on his phone and then he
was like ariel vandenberg and he's like
he's just like always showing me her
videos and i i think he's in love with
her and so he's like in love with her
content
no and like her face oh okay yeah so
that's that's kind of triggering he's
gonna have to stop
um so i just thought that was really
interesting and a great selection she's
like super funny we'd love to see like a
digital personality
thriving yeah and she's been hosting
since season one of the us so happy for
her
the house sickening like that slide was
everything
i just and that harked back to my point
number one the budget that comes with
being on cbs
the house was so nice the music the
music is
everything and then a new song for every
contestant what a man got to do
like they were just killing it the music
is the best part of love island you will
also find new
songs that you don't already know it's
so good and sometimes like when it comes
to too hot to handle i
thought that like lana and the voice
over
girl were first of all wait
too frequently like speaking like shut
the [ __ ] up it's really not about you
and their jokes were so corny and lame
but they had like a narrator on to on
love island that
really didn't chime in much and when he
did it was actually funny
yeah so i really enjoyed that yeah no
he's a big part of the show
and his and his crazy jokes so uh so
again i never watched it sometimes we
don't even see arielle in a whole
episode
like which i love like it's not about
her yeah
so here's was some of my initial
reactions like so that whole thing where
you have to like step forward for the
guy like
traumatizing trauma and of course like
it has to be that the guys because
if it were a girl like that would just
be too sad like i know we're equal but
like
we're not we can't handle we can't
handle that so i was cringing
to death when three of the guys got
nobody stepped forward for them like it
was really truly honestly painful
yeah of course like shannon and
it's so hard to remember everyone's
names yes shannon and josh goldstein i
remember his name because i'm like are
you jewish gotta look into that
um they were like the only couple who
like mutual
yeah olivia's step forward for um
for the guy who became obsessed with her
yeah bonnie
yeah it's so hard to remember i know
even the narrator said i don't know
their names yet
so did she i don't think she stepped
forward for anyone so much
i think they all did for jeremy jeremy
you guys
most of the couples were forced together
which is just so awkward so awkward but
it's really doesn't really matter who
you're coupled up with there's going to
be like a recoupling
in the next episode it just means that
you sleep in a bed with
but they all spend all their time here
together and i guess if there's a
challenge like that it'd be your partner
right but
the first coupling really really doesn't
matter well it's sad because josh
goldstein like thinks that he has found
the one that he's gonna win because
they're gonna be like the strong couple
and she's just one of those girls which
i
i just can't relate to people like who
are always like looking for someone
better when literally the best guy is
like standing in front of her and he's
so obsessed with her and like they could
just win together like if they just like
gave in to each other
and she's like i like the chase it's
like grow the [ __ ] off yeah i had no
time for her i had no time for that type
of laughter
she's not into him i hope he like meets
someone worthy of his commitment because
he seems like
he wants to go all in he's so cute
yeah jeremy you guys jeremy
and when he picked trina she was like so
excited and trina is like so
sweet so sweet and like i think they're
actually like could be like a cute
couple
but when trina was like getting
emotional in her confessionals like
trina just has to like
dial down like a little bit of her
desperation like it's showing a little
bit too much
and it's coming it might be a sincerity
that's coming off as desperate but
whatever it is like she's got to reel it
in a tiny bit because she's
so lovely and angelic and i think that
like a lot of the guys are into her
but she's coming off a little desperate
yeah i i hear you but i also feel like
she's i mean who wouldn't be so into
jeremy at first glance
and you have to realize that the fifth
person that comes in is going to be so
handsome because it's going to make all
these girls
step forward get away like you know it's
gonna be exciting maybe they knew that
and that's why a lot of people didn't
step forward until the last one
um but he is just something else i
really i've never seen anyone who looks
like him i was so
struck by him especially because like
that's not my usual like i don't love
the long hair
but he is just like so pretty he's
really striking like
the narrator said something so funny
lucky his hairbrush that i texted
claudia
um when we were watching together via
text he said
jeremy owner of the world's luckiest
hairbrush
so funny also true i thought that the
moment between that platinum blonde guy
christian
and cachet who likes took her wig off
said she like shaved her head before she
came here and she was like so nervous
because like
she loves the way it is but like she
doesn't know how other people are gonna
react i thought that was like literally
the sweetest moment like i was actually
gonna cry like yeah
and honestly i think that is the bravest
thing you can do like i
there's been many times when i've just
wanted to shave my head because like i
can't deal with having hair anymore
um and she just like did it right before
she was supposed to go on like this tv
show that's all about like looks and
hair and makeup
and i just think that was like an
incredibly brave thing to do i totally
agree it was a really nice moment also i
feel like all the cast
members are just like really nice people
like even and
this always happens with love island
like whenever really someone new comes
into the house like
everyone is so welcoming like oh my god
you're so beautiful like
when they all fight like it's not
competitive and competitive
which is really nice that is nice like
they're i don't know if they're told to
to be like that or i mean you should
want to be like that because he wants to
come off like an [ __ ] on television
but i feel like with too hot to handle
when there was like new people there
like
even though when i'm watching a tv show
and i'm just starting to get to know
types of show like these or like the
bachelor i'm just starting to get to
know people remember everyone's names
and then they like throw in more
contestants
i'm always like oh [ __ ] these
contestants because like i just started
to get to know these people
i can't bother remembering two people's
names i've started to [ __ ] people
and i get i get that it really does like
mix up the show and some shows can't
move forward without bringing in new
people because if everyone's coupled off
but as a viewer i'm like get the [ __ ]
out of here no but last night's
episode and casting well then we got two
new people but before we did like it
definitely left me wanting more i was
like who's next
when they were sitting on the couch
playing those games like i dare you to
kiss her
passionate cats like so stupid i was
like oh something needs to happen so i
don't feel also
then the two new guys came in and cinco
is so handsome i think he's really gonna
shake things up me too
and i'm really excited about that me too
i thought i i really like it my first
impressions were like
it's i don't know what the point of the
game is yet because i've never watched
it but i kind of just want to like roll
with it okay and i'll just
try and explain to you so like every the
map in order to stay in the house you
have to be in a couple you have to be in
a couple so like
there's always um it switches off every
week and there's always more guys than
girls or girls and guys
and at like every other episode or so
there's a recoupling ceremony where the
five girls will choose from the seven
guys everyone chooses who they want to
couple up with for the next week and
then there's two like substitutes two
people who go home oh everybody if you
don't if someone doesn't choose you
you go home yeah every week there's
people leaving and coming in which
uh makes it nice but usually in the two
seasons that i've watched the end people
who are there
it's a lot of the original cast still oh
really yeah
i mean we'll see with this but if
there's not strong connections like from
the jump then like
when new guys come in and you girls come
in like they're all gonna like have
their eyes open
yeah right like looking i mean half the
girls kira like couldn't get away from
her partner fast enough like
i think that a lot of the girls are in
couples that they're not super happy
with yeah but it's it's still so early
that they don't they don't have to be
like so
my only other issue with the show that i
realized last night is like i hate that
the show calls them
the girls and the boys like these people
aren't boys oh i never realized that
i realized it because they're like which
boy do you want to couple up with and
then in every recoupling ceremony like
i want a couple with this boy because
and everything's like the boys
yeah i just think like boys are 12. i
completely agree it's inappropriate
men or you could call them guys guys you
can call them guys i think boys is just
like the wrong word
i also really liked how they have two
separate dressing areas because like
into hot tandel it gives me so much
anxiety there's one shower that like
everyone shares and there's like
one bathroom that everyone uses in one
mirror and it's just like no way to live
yeah so i was just grateful for the
accommodation yeah it's definitely
spacious
yeah it is i'm like the girl like the
girls get to talk the guys get to talk i
enjoyed that very much there's a lot of
places to fall in love
when they were talking about their dance
moves and that guy josh was like i
really like to throw stuff up and catch
it and then they were all like throwing
an invisible ball to each other
pretending to catch it that was
very funny oh it's funny i must have
been on my phone oh my god really it was
such a cute moment
oh i enjoyed it that's really funny um
but all in all i'm a big fan like i
think
uh tonight obviously it's my birthday
party i don't know if i mentioned that
so i'm not gonna be able to watch
but i'll probably watch and we'll recap
it like maybe once or twice a week i
agree
i'm not gonna be able to do every single
night and i don't like a cliffhanger
like i want to
batch the episodes like four at a time
yeah well monday tuesday wednesday
thursday friday nights
or sunday monday tuesday wednesday
thursday i think it's sunday monday
tuesday wednesday thursday so basically
the watch droppings live schedule
yeah so maybe we recap on fridays no
maybe we recap on
i don't know i don't know we'll think
about that we'll figure it out
yeah um and that is our show yes it is
tomorrow's show will be in studio and
podcast as usual but it will be up a
little bit later just because
i plan on getting lit tonight all right
hey so stay tuned for that and just
watch my instagram stories
cool thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the facified
stories that you need to know
on youtube podcasts everywhere that you
could want to find us
is that it also available we're also
available as podcasts
and anywhere that's a nice review if you
so
dare to choose and
five stars thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the past live stories that you need to
know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast blocks all the places so
i really listen to podcasts find out the
morning toast
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing amazing thursday and we'll see
you tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
goodbye
you